Narrator: In "X-Men: Days of Future Past,"
Evan Peters was filmed
running on a treadmill
in front of a green screen
so he could then be placed
into these frozen shots,
which were filmed at over
3,000 frames per second.
On set, these actors and objects
were stabilized with wires and poles,
but these ingredients
and this spilling soup
were all added with CG.
Frozen-in-time sequences
have come a long way
thanks to advancements
in technology and CGI.
Just look at this time-freeze
scene in "The Twilight Zone."
Here, boy. Come on!
Narrator: Without CG, it was difficult
for director Douglas Hayes
to hide subtle motions
like breathing and shaking.
So he found that the best way
to cover up these unavoidable errors
was to keep moving the camera,
so viewers didn't even
have time to notice.
The movement trick is still used today,
but modern cameras also allow filmmakers
to slow down the visuals by
changing the frame rates.
Most modern movies are shot
at 24 frames per second.
If you increase the frame rate,
more images are produced,
allowing filmmakers to stretch out
and slow the scene down frame by frame.
So, for example, this moment
in 1999's "The Matrix" ...
Freeze it.
Narrator: The camera was actually running
at 96 frames per second.
And to capture "Quicksilver time"
in "Days of Future Past" and "Apocalypse,"
the "X-Men" team used a Phantom camera
capable of both filming
3,000 frames per second
and moving at 90 miles per hour.
So an action that happened in
just one second in real time
could be extended to 15 seconds.
VFX artists can also
retime a live-action shot,
a technique that was
required to make Quicksilver
look like he was moving
faster than his environment.
That meant rotoscoping the actor
out of the original shot frame by frame,
then filming him in
front of a green screen
so he could be retimed separately
before adding him back in.
Filling these scenes with
various frozen characters
and background elements can
be done both practically
and with visual effects.
And not everything in the
Quicksilver scenes was VFX.
Just look at these dishes
propped up by wires and poles.
Often practical effects in
combination with CG touch-ups
can add even more realism,
like in 2021's "The Worst
Person in the World,"
which leaned heavily into the
practical side for this scene,
in which the world freezes
around the protagonist, Julie.
Director Joachim Trier
made a creative choice
to do most of the film's
frozen-in-time effects in-camera.
Much of this was achieved
through the clever craftsmanship
of prop master Hedda Virik.
Hedda: When it works, it works,
and it creates a magic on set
that everyone is just very
excited to be a part of.
Narrator: Like when Aksel freezes
in the middle of pouring coffee.
To create this effect,
Hedda studied photos
of real coffee streams
and sculpted a replica using polymer clay.
Hedda: It's not just one line of coffee.
It's water, and water frozen
in time is always unique,
and you get those little
beautiful lines down.
Narrator: That sculpt
was used as the basis for
a negative cast, which she
poured resin into to add color.
Hedda: So you really want
that see-through, lush coffee.
Narrator: There was also
real coffee in the pot
to get the movement before
and after the frozen sequence.
So to keep the real coffee from spilling,
Hedda covered the pot's
opening with ultraclear tape.
And the resin stream was
rigged to a coffee cup
with a flexible wire so it
could be repositioned on set.
While items like the coffee stream
needed to be made from scratch,
others just needed some
clever modifications
to appear frozen.
Like these headphones, which were taped
to this extra's shirt
to maintain their shape.
Hedda: Sometimes the real thing works,
as long as there's no wind.
Narrator: Similarly, Hedda
used tape and metal wire
on a real briefcase so it wouldn't flap.
Inanimate objects are one challenge,
but keeping everything in place
gets even more difficult
when you're dealing
with living, breathing creatures.
Hedda: Animals are very
difficult to convince
and to get them to do what you want.
And I don't know any animal
that just wants to stand
still and do nothing.
Narrator: So these two
dogs in the background
are completely fake.
But the fake pups needed to be placed
in unique and dynamic ways,
so they wouldn't just
look like stuffed animals.
That included breaking
one of the stuffed legs.
Hedda: Like he's doing a little strut.
Narrator: And holding
them down with rocks,
so they wouldn't fall over.
Human actors can stand still on command,
but maintaining certain positions
for long periods of time
still requires some extra assistance
and can be painful and uncomfortable.
And we were at each location
for hours and hours.
When you're doing it again
and again and again and again,
then you're going to get tired.
Narrator: Wires are one option,
like in this shot from "Apocalypse."
But they have their own complications.
Ian: If you use wires all the time,
sometimes you'll have sort of pinching
or an unnatural kind of angling.
Narrator: So how did Hedda
get everyone to look so steady
in this final shot without wires?
Tiny wooden blocks.
She brought blocks of
all sizes to the set.
The ones she chose varied
based on the type of footwear.
On their own, the blocks
would be really easy to spot,
so Hedda covered them in
nonreflective black tape.
That way, they could
blend in to the shadow
under an extra's foot.
The best option is to cover up these rigs
with people and objects.
This moped simply has its kickstand out,
but it was blocked from the camera.
Bikes and scooters were a bit
more difficult to position,
as their kickstands are harder to hide.
So Hedda built specialized metal stands
to hold them up straight
to appear as if they were mid-ride.
Hedda: We had to position
something under one of the pedals
so that all of the weight
could be on the pedal.
Narrator: Hedda also
had to teach the extras
how to position their bodies
for the scene to look realistic.
Foremost, don't shift your weight.
Hedda: Because when you're on a bike,
you just want to go, right?
You are used to being on a bike,
and you treat it completely differently
to when you have to fake being on a bike.
Narrator: Even when you use
practical for these sequences,
a final VFX assist is crucial
to put it all together
to make it look seamless.
The bike and foot rigs, for example,
were removed digitally in post.
The same goes for those wires
and poles in Quicksilver's scenes.
While animators can
stabilize real performances
to get rid of any moving and shaking,
digital doubles give
them much more control.
So to get every detail just right,
"Days of Future Past" and
"Apocalypse" recruited
the visual effects studio
Rising Sun Pictures.
For instance, Rising Sun Pictures
created digital versions of
these students Quicksilver saves
to preserve the delicate balance
of keeping these characters frozen in time
but not frozen in place.
That's also why they created a CG version
of this table for Quicksilver to surf on.
We can use that to interact
with any effects that we're creating.
Narrator: Like here, when the animators
rebuilt a car digitally so they could add
slo-mo water splashing onto the tires.
You can drive a car through,
and that would work in the final shot.
But it's the splash that you
needed to sort of slow down
that you might not
necessarily get correct.
Because once you film something
with that element in it,
that's what you've got.
Narrator: Techniques
like facial replacement
can fix continuity errors.
As time slows down in
"Days of Future Past,"
Professor X yells ...
No!
Ian: When they actually filmed
it, his mouth was closed,
but contextually, he would've
been more into his word.
Narrator: So his original
expression was swapped
with one where his mouth was wide open.
In any one of these sequences,
there's the moment when time resumes
and everything goes back to normal.
Since "Worst Person"'s
frozen-in-time sequence
ended back with Aksel as he poured coffee,
they only had to make a single
action return to normal.
But for "Days of Future
Past," they had to sort out
all the objects Magneto
lifted into the air
alongside whatever positions Quicksilver
placed all these characters in.
On set, people and
objects were tossed around
using wires and pressurized air.
If that scene works and the timing works
as we get back into normal time,
then we'll try and keep as much as we can.
Narrator: But only the
objects within reason.
All these bits of leftover
food and extra plates
that land on the ground in
the kitchen and keep moving?
Fake.
Ian: Pizza dog, who ended up becoming
a favorite on our crew.
So, there was a journey
through the mansion
that was filmed with the cameras.
So there was pizza dog with
his jowls sort of flapping,
which was a CG head.
And here is some slow-moving footage
where we've taken various takes.
And so we would mush that journey behind
with the motion blur and the
speed so that it feels like,
"Oh, this is what it must be like."
Quicksilver: Wow!